what's going on guys
so she hear the news about Emma Watson
and miles teller almost being the stars
of lala land that's right the
oscar-nominated frontrunner that you're
quirky art friends won't shut the eff up
about almost had two very different
leads this got us thinking what other
stars were almost cast in famous roles
what are some the Hollywood stories the
legends that might have been
are there any weird old videos of these
auditions online the answers yet yes
there are so right now we're going to do
a deep dive into alternate Hollywood
universes and stars that didn't get the
part first up one of America's favorite
sitcom the office which was already one
of the UK's favorite sitcoms a who's who
of rising Hollywood stars originally
auditioned for the pilot here's a
big-time comedy star mr. Seth Rogen
reading for the part of Dwight urine is
sterile
you know what if you're in the field you
can clean the man's room by taking a
whiz on it that is actually in first aid
books written by the Red Cross also
comedy darling friend of the screen
junkie show an all-around nice guy
Patton Oswalt also read for the part of
Jim's nemesis check it out I'm trained
in this from being a sheriff's deputy
volunteer sheriff's deputy okay next up
the star of mr. show Breaking Bad and
now better call Saul Bob Odenkirk trying
his hand at Michael Scott we play hard
and we work hard sometimes we played
play hard when we should be working hard
when that's probably my fault but fire
me you know what that was a good
audition it's too bad the casting
directors over at the office said better
called Steve Carell they probably didn't
say that let's get out of the office and
venture to a galaxy far far away it's
hard to imagine anyone other than mr.
Harrison Ford playing on solo but when
it came to Casting that role Harrison
wasn't solo in the audition waiting room
they almost cast
freaking Russell check this out homicide
thanks not to to secure and I think
we're do the reward you offered and it
had better be pretty substantial to what
we've been through so where are you
taking us to now anyway to the fourth
wall of young and I've taken coordinate
to Chewbacca well there let us go the
track they want to find your faces so
they can just try to sit keeping in the
Star Wars universe let's talk about
Anakin apparently George Lucas looked at
three thousand different kids to play
Anakin Skywalker and Phantom Menace
before he finally settled on Jake Lloyd
let's see some of the kids who dodged
that bullet is killing Timmy seven years
old high really feeling like one or nine
years old
hi I'm Mike Lane right around eight and
a half I'm a pilot you know and someday
I'm going to fly away from this place
you're a pilot all my life I'm a PI you
know someday I'm gonna fly away from
this place your pilot all my life now
let's talk about a casting catastrophe
that was narrowly averted 2012
spider-man there have been plenty of
clearance some say there's too many and
I bet we'll have more before our
lifetimes are up but none of them ended
up being Hunger Games star Josh
Hutcherson despite this very extensive
screen test
luckily Hutcherson didn't get the part
and he went on to become the Hunger
Games Peeta thank goodness could you
imagine a world without Josh Hutcherson
- Pete up makes me shudder just to think
about how that really puts me in the
mood I really want to hear j-law
screaming where's Peeta we got a little
bit of that where's Peeta where's Peeta
madness I don't know where he is we all
want to know what's going on with Peeta
you know in Hollywood there are always
some stars but don't have to audition
because they've proven themselves over
and over going to be good actors and
box-office gold you know like leo but as
it turns out leo almost lost his
breakout role in Titanic - Jeremy Sisto
you know Elton from clueless would you
really have come test me come honest
answer well I - sorry Jeremy Sisto
you've been on like four syndicated TV
shows I bet you have a really nice house
way nicer than mine you know it's pretty
hard to imagine anyone other than Al
Pacino as Michael Corleone in The
Godfather
go on try to imagine it I dare you si
can do it could you
it turns out that James Caan and Martin
Sheen read for that role check it out
why are those people bothering you
Father in a day like this well that's
because they know no system can refuse a
request on his daughter's wedding day
oh good I tried to kill him my father
they did they nearly did mr. barofsky
went after him and Robert De Niro also
read for the part in The Godfather
you're going to take posted a mod on
you're gonna take them and you know what
they're gonna do to you and you know
what you're doing you knock somebody off
you take a gun you shoot them right up
against the head that's what you do you
can just you get his brains it'll be a
nice little Ivy League shoot Michael
that's what happens Cohn and De Niro
ended up getting cast and making their
mark on the Godfather series but poor
Martin Sheen was just left out to dry
you guys think it was the moustache I
bet it was the moustache here's another
audition that you think would have been
easy for casting directors
cast aside in fact this might be the
worst audition I've ever seen
here's Gerard Butler reading for Dracula
mm apart which he actually looked
understand I can make you understand
ready mine
uh not quite a breakout role for Gerard
Butler but after that he dedicated his
life to sit up all right just to cleanse
our palates let's take a look at two of
the best audition tapes of all time
Henry Thomas from ET and Daisy Ridley
from the force awakens he would have
disappointed you go ahead
taken well I'm afraid I have to Shawn
yeah take it away my but it's not my
choice the president asked me to come
here to get it don't care what the
president's anything like that ran away
I think we all learned a valuable lesson
here if you want to role cry like a baby
like I did several times during this
episode I'm good
no not mu jeremy sisto
well the fun look at what could have
been were there any famous audition
stories that we left out or are there
any parts that you think would have been
improved by a different actor let us
know in the comments section below we
want to know I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye hey guys
did you know that this end card works
with your phone now I know right click
the boxes below to watch more screen
junkies videos and click the screen
junkies logo to subscribe and get this
show honest trailers movie fights and
more